Rebecca is on Twitter Dave how come you
never consider bankruptcy if individuals
are deep in financial crisis well
Rebecca there are good people that
sometimes go through bankruptcy
bankruptcy is a devastating
life-altering decision divorce is a
devastating life-altering decision and I
don't tell people to do either one I'm
not mad at you if you do either one and
I'll help you if you do either one but
I'm not going to allow you to say Dave
Ramsey said for me to file for a divorce
Dave Ramsey said for me to file
bankruptcy so that makes it okay because
then you're gonna go through hell and
I'm gonna have that on me so you may
decide to go through that and again I'll
help you but it's not it in either case
I put them in the same category it
should be your absolute sure you've
tried everything else
and then tried everything else again it
ought to be your absolute last thing on
your list of things to do and so I find
people with bankruptcy I've been through
bankruptcy I filed bankruptcy when I was
28 years old thirty years ago and it was
hell it was awful to go through the the
leading up to it was hell going through
it was hell it is not a fun process
being that broke and broken and them
going through your underwear drawer I
want to know every little detail of your
life and everybody's got rights on your
head
it's not a good thing so it's not
something to be entered into until
you've tried everything else and too
often I find people think it's gonna fix
their stuff and it's really not gonna
fix your stuff your stuff is so screwed
by the time you get to bankruptcy if you
really file that you're stuck doing any
stuff it's over
so here's an example okay here's the
things to remember bankruptcy does not
do away with child support you still owe
it bankruptcy does not do away with IRS
debt 99% of the time
you still owe it bankruptcy does not do
away with student loan debt
you still owe it bankruptcy does not do
away with secured debt if you reaffirm
the debt to keep the car or the house
secured debt is something that debt
against an asset if you want to keep the
boat if you want to keep the car if you
want to keep the house if you want to
keep the couch if you want to keep
whatever they have a lien on you have to
agree to pay the debt you don't get to
keep the item and knock the debt off and
so I run into people who reaffirm their
car debt reaffirm their house debt
they've got student loan debt and an IRS
lien and some back child support and so
they come out of bankruptcy with all
that still there and they end up having
net net net having filed bankruptcy on
$8,000 with a credit card debt well
that's dumber than crap you didn't do
anything so if you're gonna reaffirm all
the secured debt to keep your crap to
keep the stupid stuff that you couldn't
afford in the first place then you've
you've screwed up the whole thing it
doesn't work and so if you're gonna give
up your house you're gonna give up your
car you're gonna give up your life
you'll give up everything and walk away
from the debt and start down at the
ground zero in the dirt you can do that
and it does clear off everything
everything but student loans child
support an IRS or any criminal
restitution you're not getting rid of
that you're gonna pay that as well and
so you know or I'm gonna pay payments in
bankruptcy chapter 13 bankruptcy is know
what that's called wage earners plan
which you're forced
to do by the way you're not allowed to
do a chapter 7 if you have the income to
pay payments so people go in to file
bankruptcy and they're forced by the way
the law count the calculation that the
law requires your bankruptcy attorney to
do that you can't file a chapter 7 and
wipe off the debt instead you have to
enter into a chapter 13 which is 60
months of payments if you're going to do
that you can do that without filing
bankruptcy you can face 60 months of
payments without filing bankruptcy well
there are after me there it's out of
control they're bothering me well I know
they're gonna bother you you'll think
they're gonna bother you in bankruptcy
they're not gonna call you but you try
missing one of those payments now
they're really seriously going to come
down on your head
so the problem is is that you know you
if you have a really good fight with
your wife and then you file divorce it
doesn't solve your problem because all
you've got is a relational problem and
the relational problems still there and
if you get behind on your bills and you
just file bankruptcy you've still got
the problem it doesn't solve the problem
it treats the symptom and so I you know
I'm again I'm not mad at you for filing
bankruptcy but I'm not going to be the
guy that gave you permission to file a
life altering thing in your life that
caused you to go into hell okay and most
of the time there's other options that
are better when you actually net out
what their actual net effect of your
filing is and so a chapter 7 is what
most people think of when they think of
bankruptcy that's the total liquidation
ninety-eight percent of the chapter 7
filings in the nation are no asset
filings meaning the person had no assets
left to pay against their creditors so
they're not sitting on a bunch of money
they've already used up their money or
whatever in the process right and so
they're it's um no asset case I don't
have any money to pay bills with and so
then you're looking at turning over any
of your secured
that's or you're gonna pay those
payments anyway you don't get to keep
the car without keeping the car payments
you don't get to keep the house without
keeping the house payments you don't get
to walk away from student loan debt you
don't walk away from IRS debt you don't
walk away from criminal restitution you
don't walk away from student loan debt
it's all staying it's all surviving your
bankruptcy so again by the time I met
all of that out I haven't most of the
time your final makeups are a few
thousand dollars twenty thirty thousand
bucks fifteen thousand bucks ten
thousand bucks and it's really just
because you didn't have any hope no one
showed you how you could scratch out no
one showed you how you could make it no
one showed you how you could turn this
around and it really wasn't you weren't
that far away from actually turning the
corner and I can show you how to do that
so that that's the reason and and in a
few cases where you know someone has a
five hundred thousand dollars in debt
and they have zero income and they're
gonna file bankruptcy and that five
hundred thousand is just gonna go away
in a chapter 7 bankruptcy I'm not gonna
yell at you for that I'm not mad at you
I'm not making a moral statement about
you I'm just saying let's from a
practical standpoint is it worth the
cost did you move the needle did you
change your life because you are going
to change your life in a negative way
I've been through it it's hell it is not
something you want someone you love to
go through and then a chapter 13
bankruptcy again is a series of payments
that's the two primary types of
bankruptcy chapter 7 and chapter 13 get
this 78 percent of the chapter 13
payment plans fail because the very mess
that's in people's lives the inability
to live on a budget the income problem
whatever the problem is it's still there
when you're going to bankruptcy and so
they don't make it through the pay in
the payments
and they end up rolling into a7 after
all so these things it's just it's a
it's if it helps you if it really helped
you I'd be all for it then I'm man
please I just I just want to love you
well that's all